imagine waking up and finding yourself a
year or two younger that's what's
happening to South Koreans a law passed
last December scrapping the traditional
method of counting someone's age came
into effect on Wednesday
I'm supposed to be 30 next year under
the traditional Korean age system but
with the international age I'm two years
younger it's great to feel like I'm
getting younger
traditionally South Koreans are deemed
to be a year old at Birth and every
January 1st a year is added to a
person's age the country has used the
international Norm of calculating from
zero at Birth and adding a year on every
birthday since the early 1960s but
that's mainly for medical and legal
documents while the traditional method
was used for everything else
I'm going to study abroad in the UK so I
think it's less confusing that I don't
need to explain about Korean age and
just can say my International agent of
the countries
at a briefing earlier this week a
cabinet minister said he hopes the
change will ease confusion especially
among older people who may believe they
are eligible for Senior Benefits before
they legally are we expect that legal
disputes complaints and social confusion
that have been caused over how to
calculate ages will be greatly reduced
maybe maybe not South Korea is still
keeping another age system where a
person's age is calculated from zero at
Birth like the international Norm but a
year is added every January 1st instead
of on the date of birth
that system will still be used for
compulsory military service the school
year and in determining the legal age
for drinking and smoking I was worried
that I would be banned from drinking but
I'm relieved I can still drink
South Korea now joins other East Asian
countries who drop the traditional age
counting method decades ago Florence
Louis Al Jazeera
siwanku a South Korean journalist and
publisher is joining us now live from
Stuttgart in Germany an interesting
change I was just wondering how many of
your friends and family will be very
happy to perhaps feel a little bit
younger today
well I certainly am happy myself
considering that under the old system in
Korea I was 44 but now I'm 42. and uh
but in reality in most aspects of life
as you know correspondent explain not a
lot of change is to be expected because
um in the legal system in government
documents also in healthcare the Western
Way of counting age has in fact been in
use for a long time but as your
correspondent also explained for things
such as drinking buying cigarettes doing
military service when your children go
to school we're still maintaining the
old system so if I could just if I can
just jump in there if I can just jump in
there we'll talk about the impact in a
moment let's just talk about why the
Korean government have decided now is
the right time to make that change
obviously we know all the details of
what why it's changing and how it's
going to impact on people but why do you
think they've done it now
yeah because it's tremendously confusing
for many people some people think of how
old they are in terms of the Western Way
of counting others do according to
Korean way of counting and they're in
fact more than one way of doing it the
Korean way so to speak
um yes you're one when you're born and
you turn when you're older on January
1st but some people think that your age
actually increases with Lunar New Year
not with the solar Luna New Year on
January 1st some people actually wonder
if the birthday has anything to do with
it so you can imagine that this has led
to quite a bit of misunderstanding in
the past and the popular support for
this change is incredibly high at some
70 according to most surveys you touched
on the pat on the fact of some areas
that it would impact on the day-to-day
lives of people getting a bus pass
retirement age buying alcohol or even
the age of consent but where do you
think the biggest difference or the
biggest impact will be as time grow
addresses
uh
I think the biggest impact is in the way
people in Korea think about their
relations to one another in Korea it is
very common for someone to assert let's
say superiority in social hierarchy
according to their age the older you are
the more respected you are and when you
ask people how old you are and many
people do even on meeting someone for
the first time the answer that Koreans
usually give is their year of birth not
the actual age and what the new system
now means is that people in fact have to
be quite precise in saying exactly how
old they are and this will certainly
lead to let's say renegotiation of
dynamic in the social sphere indeed I
mean I just wondered how much pushback
there may be if any at all in terms of
the generational divide perhaps the
younger generation are quite perhaps
amenable to this will the older
generation be confused by it all
uh I think certainly in some rural
communities you're bound to see a
pushback or resistance but overall
Koreans are very quick to embrace change
and this is something that in fact many
sectors of society have been pushing for
for a long time so I don't think that
there is going to be a return to the old
way of doing things I've got to say uh
Sue wonku uh it's good that both you and
me look 21 for TV purposes for your time
thanks very much for joining us from
Stuttgart in Germany
thank you so much for having me